i'm proud of the deal and it's something
that i'm happy that the men in our
locker room will get a chance to vote on
i can confidently say today that i'm
gonna vote yes guys do not worry if we
go on strike we will make sure every
player is taken care of but let's not be
fooled this deal is a really good deal
for a majority of nfl players the guys
who are saying no to the cba are as a
practical matter saying no to d smith
and the players as they cast their
ballots need to understand that
oh just some of the voices of the past
week or so as the nfl players
association continues to vote on a new
cba voting opened last thursday it has
been extended from thursday night this
week the 12th of march to saturday the
14th 11 59 pm eastern and in the interim
the nflpa has elected a new president i
thought they should postpone the
presidential vote until after they knew
what the cba outcome was because you
want to have a president who's on board
with whatever the path is for the cba
but
peter king chris sims mike floria here
pft live as we talk about the nflpa
meetings that concluded yesterday with
the election of brown's center j.c
tretter as the new union president peter
i think that no matter what happens with
this cba vote the most important job for
jc tretter is to unify the union they
are too scattered they are too divided
and my guess is that owners are
salivating at the possibility of going
back to the table and continuing to
negotiate with a group that is fighting
so zealously among itself right now
mike i i had dan kaplan in the athletic
on my podcast which drops today and one
of the things i i said to him i i said
you know the the election
of jc tretter reminds me of
the uh of what's happening in the
democratic primaries right now which is
you know the people who want the calming
unifying voice they're all picking joe
biden you know the people who want to
say let's blow it up you know they were
going to root for another candidate and
so it you know when the democrats were
going to root for sanders and and the
players were going to vote for michael
thomas
and so in this particular case i think
what happened in miami on tuesday
is that the players said hey listen dee
smith we're okay with you leading our
union and we don't want to blow this
whole thing up and whatever your
problems is with russell o kung they're
not our problems you guys work that out
but we don't want to get in this brawl
right now with this contract it's just
my feeling
but i think that that was a very good
day for dee smith
as well as for the more moderate voices
in the union
yeah agreed it definitely was a good day
for dee smith uh well i'm still very
intrigued to see where this vote's gonna
go as far as what the results are and
you know i know they extended the voting
period and we're hearing talk about you
know guys wanting to change their vote
and you know mike i know you wrote that
the the common notion out there is that
people who voted yes want to change it
back to no you know the big thing that
it does bother me okay and what mike
house started this segment you know lack
of firepower lack of stars there it's
bothering me throughout this whole
process it's bothered me in the last cba
you know where are the star players you
know hey i'm gonna give credit to a guy
like j.j watt even though he didn't give
a lot of details into why voting no or
russell wilson at least they came out
there and put themselves out there but
where are the rest of the stars aaron
rodgers seems to be the only guy who's
really
him russell wilson but aaron rodgers
seems to be the only guy in that cream
of the crop superstar guys that we talk
about in the nfl
who seems to
ever want to tackle these issues head on
and why he was there not there i don't
know that's not a good look either i
don't get that but i just don't
understand it doesn't look good look for
the players
and it just shows that it's not totally
unified there and i think nobody is
going to put more pressure on the owners
in this situation and things that get
done than the big time star players and
that's where you know i got issues with
that i didn't like that about the last
cba drew brees was the only guy that was
like that marquee guy that got involved
where was peyton manning where was tom
brady you know where's tom brady now
where are those type of guys to make a
stand and get in the player's corner
have some like wise words people would
listen to a guy like tom brady players
would listen you know i just wish that
in in general altogether there would be
more high profile faces talking about
this and trying to hash this out and
lead players in the right direction
and let me just expand on that a little
bit chris because once again i called an
audible and i moved forward and you
assumed i talked about this and i didn't
which proves you weren't listening to me
and you never do probably not there is
some consternation among the members of
the union because these meetings were
open for anyone in the union yes the
executive committee's there the board of
player representatives is supposed to be
there but j.j watt russell wilson you're
going to do a drive-by on twitter you're
not going to show up at these meetings
and engage and aaron rodgers he's the
guy that they're most upset with because
he is the packers player representative
and he wasn't there and mason crosby is
the only alternate and he wasn't there
the green bay packers players did not
have a vote on anything that was decided
by the board of player representatives
this week because aaron rodgers didn't
show up and mason crosby didn't show up
now i haven't seen any explanation as to
why he didn't show up but the belief is
he's just upset with the process he said
recently that it was disheartening the
reaction that he got from teammates when
he sent out an email explaining his
views on the cba by all appearances he's
just decided i've checked out the board
voted for the cba the players are voting
on it he didn't show up the two guys who
did get a lot of credit for showing up
at the meetings and hashing it out the
pouncey twins marquis yeah and mike they
were there engaged in the discussions
not shying away from the confrontation
that permeated the entire three days of
meetings but you know they have to learn
how to work like the owners do peter the
owners will fight behind closed doors
but the rest of us have no idea that
it's happening the players cannot if
they want to maximize their bargaining
position if this thing gets voted down
and they have to go back to the table
they do not want the owners to
understand how fractured they are
because the owners know it they're
taking notes and they cannot wait to
negotiate with these guys again because
if this deal does blow up
they the owners are going to end up with
a better deal when they finally do work
something out
well there's no question they're gonna
end up with a better deal it won't get
done this year okay so if it doesn't get
done this year that's 700 million
dollars that the owners don't have to
spend
and and i keep just asking this question
look
if you are going to vote if you're a
player and you're voting to blow up the
system and not sign anything until you
get 50 or 51
okay just understand what that means it
means you're not playing football in
2021 okay that's the first thing but
mike here's the second thing for people
who vote no i just want to say that this
is what they're voting no against
they're voting no against a 20 pay raise
for 60 to 65 percent of the players
in the nfl
and that is money
that those guys will never get back
because they will play
for the lesser figure in 2020
they're not going to get that even if
the thing is improved next year okay
they're never going to get back the
money they would have lost this year
secondly
if they vote no they're basically saying
to 11 000 former players guys who played
in the 60s 70s 80s who have a pension
max pension of 30 000
okay
they're basically saying we're not going
to give you guys a 53
hike in your pension and and this was a
huge part of these negotiations nobody
talks about it and i don't know why
baseball has always been applauded for
taking care of the people who came
before them football i've covered this
game for 36 years the biggest problem in
all of these labor fights is the
old-timers say you guys always forget
about us right they didn't forget about
him in this one and can you imagine if
this gets voted down
how incredibly ticked off that 11 000
former players are going to be
because the players
basically denied them
uh this huge raise in their pension and
when they go back to renegotiate next
year or sometime before the 2021 season
where are the players going to take
money away
uh you know because they're gonna
they're not going to have as
advantageous a contract they'll take it
away from the retired players
and so that's i just look at this and
look they should vote their conscience
they should vote whatever they want they
should understand however
what they are voting for if they do vote
no yeah i mean agreed and yes it is good
to see you know some strides made for
the older players you know as you know
my dad you know of course yeah he's
fortunate but he's got issues i know a
number of his teammates you know they're
they're falling apart you know they
played in an era where they played on
astro turf and the rules didn't take
care of players as much and it was two a
days every day and it was full pads
every day so there's guys from that
generation that really need help guys
that played in the late 60s 70s 80s and
this does go a long way to helping them
out for sure my big thing is something i
said yesterday and mike heard me say
this is just that you know
i just haven't heard enough good reasons
for a no vote you know i i understand it
at first when everything started to get
thrown out there and oh it seemed like
that things were being rushed to the to
the voting system and you know there
were some things not hashed out there
was the talk about how where did the
17th game for at first i was like yeah
this doesn't seem right i think i would
vote no but as more and more time is
gone and the more people i've listened
to
yeah i just hear more reasons to vote
yes than no i i only thing i hear about
no is oh it's been rushed oh there's not
enough on player safety okay well what
do you want done i'm just not i don't
hear ideas there i just kind of hear
anarchy and i don't know if i hear
necessarily things that make sense to me
so uh you know
again i i want to vote i want to hear
that i want it to be a yes vote i just
want better leadership from the
superstars in the nfl and i don't get
why guys weren't there i don't
understand it either you know i know
when i was a player rep last thing i
know i'm talking too much is you know i
had to go to a meeting one year and i
had a vacation scheduled and by the time
they told me this meeting was about to
come about i was already locked into
vacation and spent money on a hotel and
put a you know so i was screwed that way
and i didn't get to go to to the meeting
either i just wonder if this was
scheduled late or how how it happened
but i'm disappointed that there wasn't
more marquee players involved
they do this meeting every year in march
and i i'd like to think they communicate
with the player represented as well in
advance so they can plan accordingly for
that little slice of their offseason to
be there and if you're going to be a
player rep you need to be there and if
you're an alternate and you know that
the main guy isn't going to be there you
need to be there your team needs to have
a voice and the packers had no voice and
there are a couple of other teams i told
initially there were five teams not
represented by anyone and that
eventually as the meeting went on
whittled down to two or three but uh
you've got you've got if you're going to
take on that responsibility that's why
it's a responsibility you need to be
there but look i i think there have been
a lot of flaws with how the proposals
were communicated how the effort to get
the executive committee on board which
ultimately failed i mean god when have
we ever seen this in sports where the
body that negotiates the cba
then votes against the cba that they
negotiated this thing has been rife with
confusion peter and and this is why i'm
going to go back to my original point jc
tretter needs to get everyone on the
same page and i don't think it's going
to be possible because if this vote goes
through and the new cba is in place
there's still going to be guys who are
against it russell okung has initiated
an administrative process i think he's
going to eventually file a lawsuit to
try to blow it all up and if the vote
fails you can have a lot of guys who are
upset that players voted without
understanding the ramifications and this
thing is going to echo well into 2021
and maybe beyond and it's up to jc
tretter to find a way to get everyone on
the same page or they are going to get
destroyed at the bargaining table by the
owners
yeah what's interesting is that they
elected and i i mean look i i've never
met jc treader so i don't know him but i
mean here's a guy who you know is an ivy
league guy
who whose major was in the school of
industrial relations at cornell
and and so to me i mean he's probably a
very good guy
um you know to be the president of this
union for a while because i think they
need somebody who would be more of a
professional he had a very well thought
out and you and you sense that he he
would be a no vote on this deal he had a
very well thought out piece on twitter
um that you could link to to read you
know some clarifications on everything
uh with this deal
you know again
my only thing about that is
where has been from the union
from anybody on the board from anybody
saying hey listen
we negotiated 300 million dollars
you know of of uh of buy-ins
from the owners to give to make the
lives of 11 000 former players
a little bit more palatable and so that
to me is one of my biggest deals but but
mike i agree with you
jc tretter has got to build a bridge
between the apathetic people among the
union and and that's probably half the
players you know judging by some of the
some of the reactions that you hear
but he's got to build a bridge between
the guys who hate the deal guys who love
the deal the apathetic guys and just say
hey look you guys have to trust this
union i think he has to rebuild the
trust in the nfl pa that i think has
been lost in this negotiation
yeah and i think it's not going to be
something that happens quickly but time
is of the yes
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports